well good morning
as i've said
from the very beginning
the extraordinary measures that we
introduced during this pandemic
were always intended
as a last resort
and i stood at this very podium
and promised you that these tools would
only be used
for as long as they were absolutely
necessary
and not one day longer
the removal of these measures has always
been our objective
and something we have collectively
worked towards
for months now
we started in january when we welcome
kids back to class
and open businesses
since then
key indicators have steadily improved
at the peak of omicron wave
over four thousand people were
hospitalized with covet 19 in ontario
that number has now dropped to fifteen
hundred
while percent positivity hit
highs of nearly forty percent in early
january
it has now dropped to 13 percent
and ontario's health care workforce
continues to stabilize as we lift
directive two
and restart more surgeries
because of this progress
we heard from our chief medical officer
of health dr moore two weeks ago
and again last week
that we were fast approaching a time
when we could safely remove
restrictions over the weekend
i received recommendations from dr moore
on a plan to safely reopen our economy
and remove ontario's vaccine passport
system
i've accepted these recommendations
and so today i can announce
that beginning on february 17th
we will remove all capacity limits
except for sporting events concert
venues and theaters which will be capped
at 50 percent
some higher risk settings will also be
capped at 25 percent
social gathering limits will increase to
25 people indoors and 100 people
outdoors
organized public events will increase to
50 people indoors with no limits
outdoors
effective march the first
we intend to eliminate capacity limits
in all indoor public settings
at the same time
and at the recommendation of dr moore
we will lift
proof of vaccination requirements for
all settings
based on the advice of dr moore
and what we have learned over the
pandemic
we will need to keep masking in place
for just a little bit longer
this is an important layer of protection
that will allow us to proceed with our
reopening plan safely
my friends
like all of you
i've waited a long time for this news
but please never doubt
that the steps we took together
as difficult as they were
were absolutely necessary
and saved tens of thousands of lives
from coved 19.
and we're here today
we're able to take this step now
because of each and every one of you
because of our nurses
our doctors
hospital workers
because of every single person who
volunteered in a vaccine clinic
in every single person who played a part
in this fight
and let me be very clear
we're moving in this direction
because it's safe to do so
today's announcement is not because of
what's happening in ottawa
or windsor but despite it
on friday morning i made the difficult
decision to declare a state of emergency
in ontario
the police now have every single tool
they need
they have every resource available to
them
and we've made progress
since speaking to you last time
i want to thank our police forces for
their efforts over the weekend
the blockade at our border in windsor
has now come to an end
the ambassador bridge has reopened
we have managed the situation at the
blue water border crossing in sarnia
toronto police services have
successfully contained a second weekend
of protests in toronto
and while ottawa remains a more complex
situation
involving municipal provincial and
federal law enforcement
all three levels of government are
focused on ending the illegal occupation
to those who are still there
to those of you who are there with the
sole objective
of causing disruption and chaos
there'll be serious consequences for
this lawless activity
we will continue to raise the
consequences
against those who are holding millions
of jobs and people hostage
a number of personal vehicles were
seized over the weekend
and those seizures will continue
let me be clear
if you choose to use your vehicle to
create chaos
you will lose that vehicle
and your license
plain and simple
to our brave women and men
thank you for your service
thank you for making us
of the special powers
we have authorized to manage the
situation over the weekend
my friends i know
that this period has been one of the
most divisive times in our history
and
one of the hardest things about this
pandemic
is the way it's fractured us as a
society
differing views about government
policies
the limits of personal freedoms
different views about vaccines
public health measures
and what steps are necessary
all of it has polarized us in a way that
we could have never imagined
i've experienced this in my own family
it's been one of the hardest things my
family and i have ever gone through
but for all of this
i can still take comfort in knowing
that there remains so much that unites
us
there's so much that still holds us
together
and i take comfort in knowing
that this awful pandemic will soon be
behind us
and as hard as this period has been
time will heal this pain
and we will come out
on the other end of this ordeal stronger
more resilient and more united as
canadians
thank you
and god bless the people of ontario
we'll go to the phone line for questions
just a reminder it's one question one
follow-up first question please
your first question comes from chris
rashoe with the toronto star please go
ahead hi chris
oh hi thanks hi there thanks for taking
my questions i'm just wondering if you
can be a bit more specific about the
masking mandate um what kind of things
will you be looking at
in order for that to happen for it to be
dropped yeah i'll pass that over to the
doctor more
thank you well i agree with the premier
all of the metrics are improving
dramatically in terms of the number of
people hospitalized number of people in
the intensive care unit the percentage
of tests that are positive so we'll
continue to monitor those data sets
as well as the ongoing availability of
pcr to make a decision on masking
as you know we've always moved public
health measures in a staged phase and
evidence-based approach so we're opening
up on the 17th again on the first and
after that time period typically uh two
weeks thereafter we'll review all of the
data and make further decisions on any
other public health measures follow-up
yeah thank you um premier i'm just
wondering if you can talk a little bit
about how you feel about the federal
government using the emergencies act i
mean the military's been used for
coca-19 for bc floods and i'm just
wondering how you feel about the
military stepping in potentially uh for
the convoy protest
well i'll be uh having a conference call
with the prime minister in the premieres
that quarter after ten so i may have to
cut us off sooner
but i'm not too sure what the prime
minister's gonna discuss with us
uh but i will tell you i'll support the
federal government
and any proposals they have to bring law
and order back to our province to make
sure we stabilize
uh our our businesses and trade around
the world as the world is watching us
right now
wondering if it's a stable environment
to to open up businesses and expand
businesses
these occupiers
they're doing the total opposite what
they they say they're there to do
they're hurting hundreds of thousands of
families
millions of jobs across the province
i've been speaking to numerous ceos of
fortune 500 companies wondering if they
should continue to expand well my
message to them yes we're open for
business continue to expand
and we will guarantee you a stable
environment and to make sure we get
goods from one side of the border to the
other
next question
your next question comes from cynthia
mulligan with city news please go ahead
hi cynthia hi premier
you you made a point of saying that
your easing of measures sooner has
nothing to do with the protest but i am
going to ask you
does this decision have anything to do
with politics versus science we know
there's an election coming soon you
don't want any of your base splintering
off to
other groups that are forming out of
these protests so how much of this
actually
is keeping an eye on the upcoming
election
well first of all cynthia uh despite the
the protesters this plan was in place
long before
the protests uh were out there
and i wouldn't call them my my
supporters necessarily i think it's a
mix a bunch of of everyone down there
but at the end of the day we need law
and order uh our country is at risk
right now it's not just happening here
in ottawa it's happening in bc and
alberta
new brunswick and i've been in
conversations with all the premiers
this is unacceptable we won't accept it
we're going to move forward we're going
to make sure that we get back to normal
as quickly as possible again despite
the occupations we're going to continue
uh focus focusing on
making sure that we have a safe
environment for companies to do uh
business and trade here in ontario
follow-up
and yet premier uh our our major trade
route was was very much impacted and
halted the last few days this question
is from my colleague adrian gabriel and
he wants to know you know with so many
border cities in this province that are
key economic shipping points what are
you doing right now to ensure
that our borders aren't taken hostage
again
well we will stabilize the ambassador
bridge with the great work
of our opp and all other police agencies
right across the province we're working
collaboratively with the municipal
police and federal authorities as well
and we're going to make sure those
borders are secure that
vehicles and trucks and transports and
people can get across the border
peacefully i'm not going to tolerate
anarchy
at our at our borders or anywhere else
we need to get back to
get back to business
next question
your next question comes from allison
jones with the canadian press please go
ahead hey elsa
oh hi premier
um i'm wondering if you do you support
the protesters cause if not their
methods you've talked many many times
before
about how you were hesitant to enact the
vaccines mandates and certificates now
you're announcing their end do you agree
with the protesters cause
well first of all
through the advice of dr moore we
accepted the passports and through the
advice of dr moore we're going to get
rid of the the passports i understand
it's frustrating for everyone but
there's a level of frustration that you
can go out there peacefully protest but
when you start
occupying borders
international trade corridors it's game
over there's zero tolerance for that now
you're putting uh jeopardy people into
jeopardy at hundreds of thousands of
jobs plants were ready to close
i can't i can't even begin to explain
how serious this is
uh you know the world is watching and
we're going to make sure we tell the
world again as i said earlier ontario's
open for business we won't tolerate uh
any anything especially insurrections
occupations i mean occupying areas
unacceptable and i know the vast
majority of canadians
agree with that
follow-up
yes thank you um you're announcing the
end to the vaccine certificate system
what about uh vaccine mandates like in
workplaces such as long-term care is
that going to stay in place
yes well we have the mandates for the
two doses we're going to keep that in
place we want to make sure
we secure areas
for our most vulnerable and our most
vulnerable are in long-term care they're
in seniors homes and they're in in
hospitals as well
and
since we've done that
the numbers have come down as dr moore
said uh we're ramping up the surgeries
again we're stabilizing uh the hospitals
the percent positivity has gone from 40
uh down to 13
so because of the hard work that
everyone's done we're you know
seeing movement in a positive way
next question
next question comes from jeff gray with
the globe and mail please go ahead hi
jeff oh thanks hi premier i wanted to
ask you uh
uh you mentioned
more consequences possibly for for
people that are disobeying
the rules disobeying the law in ottawa
there's a lot of concern in ottawa i
think about a the the police
uh
uh not just uh being unable to handle
the
protest the situation there but uh
concerns about sympathies that the
officers might have with protesters
there's been videos that have come up
with
opp officers as well do you have any
concerns do you have confidence in the
police forces ability to handle this
protest i have a 100 percent uh
confidence and and are municipal police
officers provincial and and federal
they've done a very very
good job considering
the situation they've been thrown into
it's very fragile situation especially
when they have children at these
protests
and i encourage everyone please
take your kids home
that is the best
advice i could ever give you please take
your kids home
and
please uh end these protests you know
we're we're moving forward as a province
as a country
and uh this chaos is not not gonna be
tolerated i can promise you that so
let's all work together let's all get
back to normal together and unite this
province and unite this country
follow up
uh just with gene gears just to the to
the
vaccine passport the other option
which some have called for is extending
it to the three doses um at some point
can can you explain why that uh wasn't
the path you went down
well first of all we were seeing a
decline as i said in hospitalizations
and i just don't want to repeat
everything i just
mentioned but i think we're going in in
the right direction
and i'm confident if we we continue
moving down this path
there won't be a reason for it and i'll
pass it to dr moore thank you
well i agree with the premier we
are now down the slope from the peak of
omicron activity uh 92 percent of
ontarians 12 and over have received at
least two doses
and
6.7 million ontarians now have their
third doses so we have the level of
protection that we need to remove public
health measures uh and
have made terrific strides on on
reducing the risk our health system is
in much better position now we have 13
69 people in hospital uh today from
covet 19 394 in our intensive care unit
our decisions have been data driven
our numbers show
how ontarian sacrifices have limited the
spread of this virus our vaccination
numbers
speak for themselves
and as a result we no longer need the
proof of vaccination it served its
purpose i thank all the businesses and
communities that have used it as well as
all the citizens that have shown their
qr codes and their passports
but in our estimation given where we are
in the epidemic as of march 1st it will
no longer be necessary
last question
your last question comes from natasha
mcdonald with radio canada
please go
natasha
hi hi premier um
you say you have full confidence in the
police but this weekend residents were
using their own bodies to stop trucks
there was a hot tub on wellington street
what's your understanding of why ottawa
police are not enforcing the state of
emergency orders that you declared on
friday
well again uh you know it's a little
different situation on the bridge as
opposed to ottawa it's a little more
complicated we're working
collaboratively
with the ottawa police the opp and rcmp
but i'm really confident i'm confident
that we're going to be able to move
forward
i'm really really hoping that the people
that are occupying ottawa are going to
move on it's unacceptable that they have
a million people
held hostage right now
and again i can't stress it enough we
won't we won't tolerate it we've given
the police the the tools to do their job
and again i have confidence that they'll
they'll do that job
follow-up
but if that doesn't happen is ontario
going to ask justin trudeau to invoke a
federal declaration of emergency and are
you planning on talking about that in
your meeting with the prime minister
this morning well i i think we'll be
discussing everything at the
conference call today with the prime
minister and all the premiers
and i can assure you that the premiers
don't hold back on their comments
but at the end of the day uh all the
premiers agree with one thing
we cannot
make sure we cannot have people
creating chaos at our borders
interrupting uh trade with the rest of
the world it won't be tolerated
and we'll make sure we we take care of
it but my message
to anyone the protesters occupiers uh
this has to come to an end uh and it has
to come to an end real real quick and if
it doesn't come to an end you're gonna
have serious consequences you'll lose
your license for life you're gonna lose
your car indefinitely and we're gonna
throw every tool we have
at you to make sure we bring stability
back to our great province and our great
country
i just want to thank everyone
god bless the people of ontario and
canada
we're moving in the right direction and
we will get through this together thank
you thanks everyone